Let's suppose that two autonomous systems connect
in two different cities, San Francisco and
New York. Let's further suppose that AS1 wants traffic to destination d to enter
via New York City, rather than via the peering link in San Francisco. Well
remember that all things being equal, routers
inside AS2 will select the BGP route with
the shortest IGP path cost to the next
hop, resulting in hot potato routing. So some
routers will select the San Francisco egress, and
other routers might select the New York egress.
To override this default hot potato routing behavior,
AS1 might advertise its BGP routes to AS2
with MED values. For example, if the MED
value on the route learned, at the border router
in New York, was 10, and the MED value
from the route learned from the router in San Francisco
was 20, than instead of performing hot potato routing, all
of these routers that would ordinarily be closer to the
San Francisco egress, would instead pick the route learned via
the New York egress. Because the preference for a lower
MED value comes before the preference for a next hop
with the lower IGP path process. So all of these
routes would instead be carried over AS2's
backbone network and exit via New York.
Thus MED overrides hot potato routing behavior
allowing NAS to explicitly specify that it
wants another neighboring AS to carry the
traffic on its own backbone network, rather
than dumping the traffic at the closest
egress and forcing traffic across the neighbor's backbone.
MEDs are typically not used in conventional
business relationships, but they're sometimes used, for example,
if AS1 does not want AS2 free riding
on AS1's backbone network. So effectively MED allows
AS1 to say, yes, I will connect or peer with you, but it is your
job to carry the traffic long distances across
the country. This mechanism is sometimes used when
a transit provider peers with a content
provider, and the transit provider doesn't want the
content provider essentially getting free transit through
the neighboring AS. In the absence of MED
overriding any behavior, typically what will happen
is a router inside the AS2 would learn
multiple routes via internal BGP to different egress
points for the same destination d, and it
would simply pick the next hop or, the egress router, with the lowest IGP path
cost. In this case, 5. It's very common practice to set these IGP costs in
accordance with distance, or propagation delay, thus
resulting in routers inside the AS picking shorter
paths. Now one problem with this notion of
hot potato routing is that a very small
change in IGP path cost can result in
a lot of BGP routing changes. Remember that
it's probably not just one destination that's being
routed through the San Francisco egress, but maybe tens
of thousands of routes. So a single IGP
path cost change can result in rerouting of tens
of thousands of IP prefixes in BGP. People
have looked at various ways to improve the stability
of BGP routing, by decoupling the IGP and the
BGP, in this part of the route selection process.